so as you guys know I have been
following the story of Adam 22 and his
wife so for those of you that don't know
or maybe you're now just tuning in Adam
22 went viral this summer for
essentially loaning out his wife to
another man Adam and his wife lonard the
plug got married in July then after that
they decided they were going to shoot
their first corn scene with another guy
so essentially Adam wasn't there and
Lena and this guy face and love did the
deed and then it went viral everybody on
the internet was commenting about it and
it was interesting because Adam 22 goes
after me he says Pearl is such a
misogynist after we had a nice interview
after we had a nice interview um so I
thought to myself what who's the real
misogynist you're the one loaning out
your wife and really I've even you know
I actually met um Sky Bri when I was in
La for my interview with him and the
funny thing was she was all oh I love I
love corn all that stuff now now she's
saying she had to quit because she had a
boyfriend so really if we're going to go
off of misogyny points I say he's the
real misogynist he's the one that
doesn't like women I'm at least being
honest so anyways now I have to I have
to give credit where credits do this is
very creative I don't think I've ever
seen this before Adam is now making a
reality show to see who gets to do the
with his wife let's pull it up I'm Lena
the plug I am an adult Creator my name
is adam22 and I co-own plug talk with my
lovely wife we interview a different
girl every week and then weu them at the
end but we've only ever done it with
other women so we've arranged this whole
challenge to find the perfect guy to be
our first ever boy boy girl through
Lena that came ready to you want to do a
dance off oh yeah I would love to see a
dance
off you tell me this guy that's por let
me get in the room with her
by you want to get out no
no we going to get you out of the
situation so long to get this improved
on
YouTube I really have no words I really
I I
really okay I've I've made my points on
this before so I'll just say it again
that is selfish it is selfish to trade
family values for money it is selfish to
think that there is a cost that is worth
putting inappropriate internet behavior
that your children will see on YouTube
he has a daughter and what is he
teaching his daughter that this type of
stuff is okay there is a comment Adam 22
comments who will be the next man to
bang my wife we created a new reality
show to find out dropping next
week Navy says I don't even see them as
a couple anymore just business people
with a kid so sad to see what money can
do my biggest point is why get
married why must you disrespect the
sanctity of marriage they didn't do any
of this until they got married it it
really is an insult to the people that
take marriage seriously and it degrades
the institution in itself this is why I
say that really marriage should just be
reserved for religious people and all of
this polymer open [__] should just be in
long-term relationships I don't see the
point of getting married if you're going
to do this crazy stuff pereles Perry
says I'd bang a thousand men before I
let another man bang my woman
you might be a little gay I won't lie to
you I'm sorry I don't know about that I
don't know what what you pick but that
that might be I I appreciate the
sentiment okay I Q cab your kids will
see all of this yes that was my point
you know people do what they're going to
do make your money whatever but why do
things that will embarrass your family
and in the times of the past you knew
that you were not meant to embarrass
your family so there was things that you
did not do or you were at least socially
shamed but now people make a bag off of
this and really it shows the problem
when you put money above family in
society so and
another I guess idea that seems unlikely
and fake and just out there is actually
sex dolls so I would never think in my
right mind that any guy that I know
would ever want a sex doll that like
what what guy would want a an like a
fake like an
artificial weird weird weird weird um
but I guess men want it so bad they're
they're really into these sex doll
there's a man breaking into a store
going viral because he stole a sex doll
let's pull it
up
and they say shivalry is
dead and they say chivalry is done and
so Andrew Tate commented on this he says
romantic relationships in 2023 baby
Diego weighs in and says this is what
women have men doing these days it is
sad discount Katie I'm just interested
to see what's going to happen when the
AI robot girlfriends come out it's just
going to get weird yeah like they
haven't even gotten out yet what is the
world going to be like with AI robot
girlfriends a scary place I don't even
like even this is making me feel weird
I'm like what the hell is that it show
it's kind of a a sign of the times and I
was thinking about the history of
gynocentrism because a lot of the stuff
that we say is like new really isn't new
it started a thousand years ago this
whole trend of putting women on a
pedestal women are so amazing you know
there's writings from the 1800s about
the men saying that women's standards
were too high so none of this is new but
what I will say is I think every
generation the women's standards get
higher and higher the women's narcissism
gets higher and higher and higher and
it's to the point where there is going
to be an entire industry Outsourcing
girlfriends and wives and what would
happen and seriously guys what would
happen if they made artificial wounds
you know and I wonder if in the next 50
years there's going to be more babies
born in a test tube than born in an
actual womb